hey guys Pete here some interesting game
of thrones related news this week that
doesn't have anything to do with season
seven or season eight HBO has actually
put out two news that is really exciting
for the spin-offs or prequels or
whatever you want to call it and this
will not contain any spoilers so this is
for anybody who wants to watch now we've
known for sure that there was something
in the works but we didn't really have
any details I made a long video a couple
months back when we got some news from
Casey boys who's the head of programming
at HBO he came out around the time that
Wes world was winding up and around any
time when Game of Thrones was poised to
win a bunch of awards saying that he was
in talks with Georgia or Martin now
Martin kind of dodged everything saying
neighborhood just needed to finish Game
of Thrones season seven and season eight
but obviously something was going on
behind the scenes this week we've
learned that there is not just one idea
in the mill but for what that means
we'll get into a little bit later but
let's look at what we heard from
Entertainment Weekly was the first
source that dropped this James Hibbard
from ewi that HBO has taken the unusual
step of developing four different ideas
from different writers does that mean
that there'll be four different projects
developed not necessarily but four is a
pretty nice number so this could mean
that things will get massively expanded
on HBO or it could mean that there will
be another full-on series with a couple
of other movies or something like that
to go along with it on the other hand it
could mean that they'll start out with
four ideas and narrow it down to one and
that's all we'll see right at the
beginning
now Rivard went on to write that the
most of the writers that were involved
with this announcement have major
theatrical film experience and what's
awesome from my point of view and I
think a lot of other fans is that George
RR Martin's personally involved in two
of the projects so the ideas come from
Max Borenstein he directed Kong Skull
Island and Fox's Minority Report he was
involved with that Jane Goldman who is
involved with Kingsland The Secret
Service
an x-men first class and she'll be
working directly with Martin Brian
Helgeland I think I'm saying that right
who's responsible for a Knight's Tale
and LA Confidential and then Carly Rae
who has worked on Mad Men and the
leftovers and she'll be the other person
who's working directly with Georgia or
Martin when asked about any more details
the only thing we get from HBO itself is
that these shows or more accurately
ideas will explore different time
periods of George RR Martin's vast and
rich universe the other thing that we
found out which we didn't know at all
before was that the showrunners a game
of Thrones David Benioff and Dan Weiss
they said they were not going to be
involved in any future projects we found
out that they're actually going to be on
as executive producers out of this group
the one I'm most excited about would be
carly rae and george RR martin working
together primarily because these are
shows you know carly rae has worked on
shows that i I'm familiar with and
watched and enjoyed madman was good she
was a contributing writer on earlier
seasons and then in the final season if
I remember correctly she was considered
a staff writer and the leftovers is
whatever it's put its prestige TV or
whatever they call it nowadays but I
enjoy that show I enjoy the writing it's
not the most popular show but it's
definitely a good story I would love to
see what she comes up with while working
with george RR martin Hibbert a TW says
shows repeatedly and I don't know if
that means he knows something more than
what is actually written here but in
HBO's statements they say wife's and
Benioff continue to work on finishing up
the seventh season and are already in
the midst of writing and preparing for
the eighth and final season but they
have kept them up to date on their plans
and they will be attached along with
george RR martin as executive producers
on all projects we will support them as
they take a much deserved break from
writing about Westeros once the final
season is complete the article goes on
to say that the prequel or spin-off
development battle is sort of like what
Disney does with their Marvel and Star
Wars brands rather than how a TV network
in this case exactly HBO tends to deal
with the retiring
series we know that Game of Thrones is
going to end after season 8 at least the
main series because that's the way
george RR martin intended it and Dan and
Dave have always stuck to that idea Game
of Thrones o is not a regular TV show
and HBO is not a regular television
network for that matter now they have
never done a spin-off or a continuation
of a series but they've never really had
one like 18 I mean they've had the
they've had really big ones don't get me
wrong I mean the biggest ones and
they've kind of helped to open up the
world then to where a lot of the shows
that we watch another network are
possible but at the same time it's an
international blockbuster Game of
Thrones is over-the-top huge and really
only rivaled by The Walking Dead which
is on regular TV HBO is a subscription
service and last season Game of Thrones
had twenty 3.3 million viewers in the US
alone plus they win a bunch of Emmys
there's a lot of merchandising that goes
along with the series so it's really
there's no other serial TV project
that's exactly the same and the books
themselves are huge in their own right I
mean they are gigantic Hibbert says and
I agree that you know there is a variety
of different combinations and options
that are on the table and you know some
of them could end up being miniseries or
movies or anything along those lines for
those of us who have read all the main
series books and you know the Song of
Ice and Fire books plus the related
titles the dunk and egg books the world
of Ice and Fire book the world book that
brings in a lot of different historical
references but you know before the
actual main series and then the stories
that are released in anthologies with
other writers stories like the princess
and the Queen and dance of the Dragons I
mean there's just an unlimited amount of
content that they could use HBO itself
says there is no set timetable for these
projects we'll take as much or as little
time as the writers need and as with all
our development we will evaluate what we
have when the scripts are in so this
really does leave the door wide open you
know and it's really exciting for those
of us who have
speculating on what the prequel might be
this further confirms that there will be
in my opinion at least one more series
but also gives the room that there might
be multiple ones which is the ideal
situation that most of us have been
hoping for as mentioned I have made a
video where I went into the most likely
different choices that they have and
what makes the most sense I hope you
guys will check that video out after
you're done with this one because
there's no reason for me to make the
same video twice there's no new content
so that video is still relevant there's
also a great conversation in the
comments they're already in place so you
can see what you think based on what
other people are hoping for or what they
think legitimately will be made one
thing I came away from after making the
video was that Aegon's conquest would be
a great option originally when I made
that I was a little bit on the fence
about whether that would be good or not
and how much they would actually have to
spend on CGI for the dragons but some
people came with some pretty good input
and I think that that would actually be
fantastic same thing with malaria though
the falls the rise and fall of Valerio
would be fantastic I just don't know if
it's possible to put in anything more
than maybe one of these miniseries so
that you know those that idea is a
little bit better than it was but
otherwise you know the story is the same
the content is the same and we can only
speculate as to what we think
HBO might do with it all the only thing
that's certain at this point is that
there are exactly 13 episodes of Game of
Thrones left the characters that we know
and have been following for these last
six seasons are their stories will be
concluded by the end and we will find
out whether anyone will be on the Iron
Throne by the end of it all and what the
big threat from the north and the White
Walkers is going to end up being the war
for the dawn is been prophesized and it
will definitely come to light I imagine
this idea that they kind of hid the
azure high stuff in the new season seven
photos makes me think that they're most
likely going to give us an idea of who
that is and then we also have you know
the actor who plays Jamie going around
kind of snowing a lot of stuff because
he is in this new movie on Netflix and
he has kind of let some things slip and
he usually kind of does but I think I'm
going to make a separate video about
that because some of it we've already
known some of it we've already
speculated but this video is about the
spin-off so let's finish it off here of
course you can leave a comment of what
you want to see and let me know what you
think do you think there's going to be
more than one project or do you think
this is basically just a deathmatch to
see who could come up with the best
project and we'll only get one prequel
spin-off that involves something from
George RR Martin's that's a Song of Ice
and Fire universe I'm not going to lie
about for them my wish list is the doom
the rise and fall of Valyria Robert's
rebellion would be great in this short
series or even a long series but you
know not by itself I don't want to be
the only one and Duncan egg is great I
don't care if it's not exactly the same
it's still really enjoyable and there's
a lot of blood Raven stuff going on and
I'm a big fan of blood Raven so I would
like to see that plus there's black fire
you know I really mentioned the
Blackfyre rebellion in my original video
and people really like those stories so
that's always there too but if that's
the case if there are four different
things that spin off do you think that
the show and the franchise will
experience like people having fatigue I
don't know let me know what you think I
still have a book giveaway going on so
if you check out the other video you can
get more details about that it's for my
subscribers and those of you who leave a
comment will be entered thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon